we did get a headline out of the trial a
Kleiner decision on pal promotion wasn't
gender-based so kleiner perkins decision
to not promote how the jury saying
wasn't gender-based also we're getting
more news out here Kleiner's a firing of
pal wasn't based on gender like i just
said so that is that what the jury is
saying the sort of weeding through what
we're hearing from this verdict Cory
what's your reaction here to this
headline that Kleiner's decision on pals
promotion wasn't a gender-based so so
that's significant because we mentioned
two of the complaints are that she did
not advance further because because of
her complaint because of her gender so
and what that also suggests that could
have a even if she's to be their find
against kleiner for some of the the
facts in the case if they think that she
was not going to advance an affirm her
claim on tens of millions even a hundred
million dollars in the future earnings
would be significantly lessened because
she wouldn't have continued to work
there and earn that money and that's one
of the issues that the jury would face
even if they found for her on any cows
Cory we're continue to get some
headlines that are trickling out the
next one I'm seeing is that kleiner
perkins failure to promote how wasn't a
retaliation so a lack of promotion
wasn't gender-based and lack of
promotion was not a retaliation Cory so
again so we're gonna hear that kind of
answer on on both the claims of
promotion and advancement so making a
general a junior partner from going from
junior to senior partner we're also
probably gonna hear the same thing about
the money whether or not she was not
given raises because of that they could
find differently the logic might suggest
that would find the same on both counts
it's the kleiner perkins fights off
ex-partner Ellen pauza gender bias
claims as we have been reporting of
course the jury finding that Pao's
firing was not due to gender bias it was
also not due to retaliation so again
kleiner perkins is able to at this point
fight off Ellen pals gender a bias claim
there are four there are four counts
here there are there are four issues and
just to make it clear that none of them
have to do with sexual harassment they
have to do with the promotion and the
retaliation because of relationship that
might or might not existed inside of
Kleiner Perkins
with Ellen Pao